comenzamos reporteros de france 24
los chilenos acudirán a las urnas este
25 de octubre para votar un referendo
histórico que pretende cambiar la
constitución adoptada durante la
dictadura militar de augusto pinochet
este voto será la culminación de un año
de grandes protestas sociales el
gobierno respondió a ellas con una
represión que llevó a hechos señalados
como una violación a los derechos
humanos más de 12 mil detenidos 31
muertos y entre los heridos 400 68
personas perdieron un ojo a causa de los
tiros de la policía las víctimas se
convirtieron en un símbolo en el país y
son la prueba viviente de la brutalidad
policial
ahora mutilados por haber exigido más
justicia social no dan el brazo a torcer
y quieren acabar de manera definitiva
con la herencia autoritaria y neoliberal
del régimen de pinochet la autora de
este reportaje que veremos es sin gripe
opinión ella nos acompaña y le
preguntamos a ingrid porque el pueblo
específicamente quiere este cambio
y lo que comenzó este malestar nacional
el año pasado fue un rechazo masivo del
sistema actual porque como dijiste la
constitución actual no ha cambiado desde
la dictadura de pinochet que terminó
hace 30 años
esta constitución fue diseñada para que
el modelo neoliberal establecido por
pinochet no fuera cuestionado por
gobiernos futuros después del retorno de
la democracia pero el resultado de este
modelo es que hoy en día chile es el
séptimo país más desigual del mundo la
gente protesta principalmente contra la
desigualdad la falta de vivienda el
desempleo masivo y la extrema pobreza
pero ahora también contra la represión
estatal por parte de la policía la cual
ha herido seriamente a cientos de
manifestantes en el último año como lo
verán en este reportaje gracias a
singles de invitados entonces a ver el
siguiente reportaje
[Música]
en blanco
se encontraron delante del palacio
presidencial para el aniversario número
47 el golpe de estado de augusto
pinochet en memoria de los miles de
opositores políticos asesinados
[Música]
en el cortejo una nueva generación de
víctimas son muertos de ese día hay más
de una decena de la multitud como nicole
y jose ambos perdieron un ojo a causa de
los tiros de la policía durante las
manifestaciones que sacuden a chile
desde hace un año
[Música]
nicole fotógrafa perdió la visión de su
ojo izquierdo hace 8 meses su
acreditación le importa poco a los
policías que decidieron expulsar la
estamos grabando un documental
así es su trabajo pero estamos diciendo
el grave de afuera
en guantes tanto en el entorno venta en
ti mirando están como persiguiendo
en un año- 468 personas han sido heridas
en los ojos por la policía
antidisturbios
jose es una de las últimas víctimas
perdió su ojo hace dos meses
ellos escogieron una fecha simbólica el
aniversario del golpe de estado para
pedir el fin de la herencia de la
dictadura militar
[Música]
qué tal
estos huertos se convirtieron en los
mártires del movimiento social chileno
símbolo de la represión ultra violenta
de las autoridades para ahogar la
protesta jose vive en la periferia de
santiago hace apenas dos meses este
electricista sin antecedentes pasaba en
bicicleta por su barrio cerca de una
manifestación herido por un tiro de
cartucho de escopeta que disturbios
perdió su ojo derecho
[Música]
yo estoy retenido en mi bicicleta
el militar apunta
se tomó su tiempo para disparar no
solamente me llegó en el ojo sino que
también me sacó un diente me partió el
labio
me pegó aquí bueno ya se me sonaba ya se
me sanó la parte de acá
en el suelo las manchas de sangre dan
cuenta de la gravedad de la agresión fue
un tiro sin aviso aunque josé no
representaba ninguna amenaza para el
militar dos meses después con sigue
luchando por superar este trauma
cuesta mucho
a causa de su comparecencia ya no puede
trabajar no recibe ninguna indemnización
por parte del estado
así como me sucedió a mí le puede
suceder a cualquier persona que acá en
la población que siguen habiendo
personas con trauma ocular de rabia
duele duele que se vengan a meter los
militares y los carabineros que la
población y siguen atacando a la gente
por solamente verdes dignidad porque nos
está pidiendo esa cosa solamente
dignidad
desde hace un año un movimiento social
sin precedentes acude a chile'
manifestaciones gigantes para denunciar
las políticas neoliberales impuestas
durante la dictadura
la salud la educación y las pensiones
quedaron a cargo del sector privado la
clase media se endeudó de manera masiva
[Música]
[Aplausos]
estas manifestaciones han sido
sistemáticamente reprimidas por la
policía provocando violentos
enfrentamientos
desbordada la policía antidisturbios no
duda en disfrutar la multitud 31
personas son asesinadas más de 2.200
resultan heridas por esos tiros de
municiones antidisturbios
[Música]
con la llegada del cover 19 las grandes
manifestaciones se prohibieron chile
restableció el estado de emergencia y el
toque de queda a las afueras populares
de santiago los militares son
omnipresentes
aquí es donde viven y con la fotógrafa
que perdió un ojo en las manifestaciones
hace parte de las pocas víctimas en
atreverse a pedir justicia así se veía
su ojo unos días después de su agresión
qué feo
nueve meses después sigue sufriendo de
estrés postraumático
pero para negro recibió un tiro de bala
antidisturbios en pleno rostro en la
víspera del año nuevo mientras iba a
cubrir una manifestación este es el
vídeo grabado por las personas que la
ayudaron
esa noche en el barrio en menos de una
hora y media tres personas perdieron un
ojo espero que ellos vieron la cámara el
micrófono que llevaba yo en mis
compañeros y dispararon con intención de
herir lamentablemente en chile se
convirtió en una táctica de represión
hacia los manifestantes y disparar a la
cara a los ojos porque es súper efectivo
inmovilizar a una persona de por vida de
hecho entre los 468 tuertos sólo unos
cuantos tienen el valor de contar
públicamente su historia se convirtieron
en los rostros de la campaña por un
cambio de constitución
soy fabiola campillay y el 26 de
noviembre de patricio maturana dispara
una bomba directo a mi cara y la cual me
deja sin visión y ni gusto ni olfato
exigimos justicia el plebiscito del
pueblo apruebo
después de la grabación de este vídeo
fabiola tuvo que volver a ser ingresada
otra vez en este hospital tras una grave
recaída
ah qué bonito
con la fotógrafa vino a apoyarla
y vamos a seguir luchando y vamos a
dejar toda la calle para que la
impunidad no siga pasando este es el
vídeo de la agresión contra favor
agravado por los policías se filtró en
las redes sociales y provocó un
escándalo
los policías se felicitan por su disparo
en directo de gas lacrimógeno aunque
está prohibido en su protocolo de
estabilidad
[Música]
en menos de menos de manos
la policía suspende el agresor de sus
funciones pero sigue estando en libertad
elizardo protege a sus agentes sólo tres
de ellos han sido condenados por heridas
oculares al contactar la la policía
chilena rechazó nuestras peticiones de
entrevistas
los policías pueden contar con el apoyo
de los diputados de la mayoría
presidencial el diputado conservador
negocia al perú es miembro de la
comisión de derechos humanos se
sorprende al ver a los muertos haciendo
campaña para cambiar la constitución
yo no creo que tenga que ver con lo que
sucedió en chile desde el punto de vista
de eventuales abusos en materia de
derechos humanos acá la pregunta no es
esa acá la pregunta es si es que chile
necesita para crecer en su desarrollo
social partir su constitución desde cero
ante la presión en las calles algunos
diputados de su partido hacen un llamado
para votar por esta nueva constitución
él está totalmente en contra pero
creemos que el rechazo no es sinónimo de
inmovilismo sino que el rechazo es
sinónimo de cambios graduales de
responsabilidad de moderación
habían autores que decían que
latinoamérica o hay dictaduras militares
o hay revoluciones y yo espero que aquí
triunfe la gradualidad y la moderación y
no la revolución constitucional que
quieren algunos sectores extremos
sin embargo hoy en día más del 60% de
los chilenos se declaran a favor de este
cambio de constitución una gran oleada
integrada por las mujeres
esta mañana se reúnen delante del
estadio nacional de santiago
este mente conocido por haber servido
como campo de entrenamiento y tortura
durante el golpe de estado militar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
estas acciones de choque son virales en
las redes sociales este referendo es la
ocasión para que ella se le pongan fin
al conservadurismo de la sociedad
chilena
para no ser un momento súper importante
tenemos que seguir en la lucha
tenemos que hacer que nuestras voces
escuchemos que se viene el plebiscito y
debemos todos votar empleo para que sea
una convención constituyente en donde
podamos incluir a nuestros pueblos
originarios y si hubiera mujeres
e
tres de ellas aceptaron encontrarse con
nosotros nos mostraremos sus rostros
pues temen represalias estudiante
emprendedora ingeniera tienen entre 20 y
30 años la mano en el ojo para apoyar a
los puertos ese gesto se convirtió en el
símbolo de su protesta
la criminalización de la lucha es
terrible acá en chile no podemos
manifestarnos de ninguna forma porque
todo eso nos repercute en nuestros
trabajos están grabando dinero en
consejos
[Música]
en esos colectivos feministas son
fuertemente reprimidos incluso los más
conocidos
[Música]
las tesis las autoras de este himno
feminista mundial fueron clasificadas
entre las 100 personalidades más
influyentes del año 2020 por la revista
'time' sin embargo en chile son
perseguidas por la justicia por haber
publicado este vídeo en julio pasado
walk observas ters y los pacos nos
persiguen lanzan gases golpean torturan
violan destruyen nos ciegan
era la represión finalmente la que hizo
que se sumarán más y más
hoy en día una gran mayoría de la
sociedad chilena exige un cambio de
constitución un acceso más equitativo a
la salud de las pensiones y a la
educación son sectores privatizados
desde hacía más de 40 años demasiado
caros para la clase media las tres se
han endeudado mucho durante sus estudios
trabajo para poder pagarme el instituto
y poder tener un plato de comida es una
trabajo no puedo estudiar porque no me
da para una vez ahí a mi trabajo le
alcanza para poder pagarme lado porque
la plata se va en arriendo comida abasto
y agua
principal ahora para nuestra trajes
cambiar la constitución chile está en
una encrucijada a pesar de la pandemia y
de la represión se han anunciado grandes
manifestaciones en las próximas semanas
seguimos en medio de la pandemia el kobe
19 le permitió al gobierno prohibir las
protestas
[Música]
si en efecto los manifestantes se
detuvieron en marzo cuando el presidente
piñera prohibió las aglomeraciones de
500 personas o más para contener la
propagación del virus
y fue la primera vez desde octubre de
2019 que la plaza italia plaza principal
donde ocurrían las protestas en santiago
estaba vacía el gobierno incluso
aprovechó la oportunidad para reformar
la plaza reformar sus monumentos que
estaban llenos de grafitis pidiendo su
dimisión pero a pesar de la estricta
cuarentena que se estaba llevando a cabo
en santiago los manifestantes
encontraron una alternativa para hacer
campaña contra el gobierno sin descanso
como por ejemplo ayudando a los
ciudadanos desempleados afectados por la
pandemia así que escuchemos lo que
tienen que decir
no se preocupa de la gente de población
mucha gente está pasando hambre a través
de esta pandemia que está sin trabajo
entonces nosotros como jóvenes queremos
ayudar y una forma de luchar y ayudar a
esto haciendo acopio de nuestra américa
esperando de escalerillas
ellos están luchando por el resto que
somos más de edad o los que no podemos
por enfermedades
a prueba nueva constitución y eso por
eso tenemos que votar que despegando
esta constitución
que todo cambio
que el riego no se haga más rico que
tengamos salud y más educación digna
jubilación digna
que vendrá después el cambio que espera
el pueblo
lo que vemos en este momento es que
después de la tregua impuesta por la
pandemia de coronavirus otro episodio de
violencia policial en días pasados
parece haber desatado una nueva ola de
disturbios en santiago
un vídeo viral motion policía empujando
a una adolescente de un puente de 7
metros de altura sobre un río y desde
entonces se ha estado protestando todos
los días en la plaza italia en el centro
de santiago tal como se veía antes de la
pandemia con la misma violencia y estas
protestas probablemente crecerán en los
próximos días con el aniversario de los
disturbios del año pasado
por el momento no está claro si el
próximo referendo va a calmar las cosas
porque aparte de la nueva constitución
los chilenos también están pidiendo la
renuncia del presidente piñera y
justicia por los abusos policiales pero
por ejemplo de 468 casos de personas que
perdieron un ojo en las manifestaciones
sólo tres policías han sido sancionados
gracias a ingrid y ponyo por habernos
acompañado por traernos este reportaje a
ustedes también gracias por acompañarnos
y recuerde que puede ver esta emisión en
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima semana
[Música]